my nan birding friends often marvel at
my ability to identify birds at a
distance in flight or hopping in a bush
invariably they will say something like
how do you know that it just looks like
expect to me or your vision is obviously
way better than mine I can hardly tell
that was a bird now while this all might
be flattering to my birding ego I am
definitely nobody special in the
exciting world of birding identification
but I've learned through many hours in
the field the subtle and sometimes not
so subtle ways to identify Birds we do
this all the time and consciously with
people we know for example I can pick
out my wife walking away from me in the
distance in a crowded shopping mall they
are both obvious and not so obvious
clues that lead me to my conclusion her
blonde hair is an obvious piece of the
puzzle and her distinctive clothing is
another these are basic ID tools like
size color and shape that we've already
covered in previous lectures but the way
she walks might not be so apparent to
anybody else trying to identify her and
the particular manner in which she
flicks her hair is something that is
unique to her and helps me separate her
from other people in the mall it's only
because I have spent so much time with
her that I recognize these subtle
behaviors and of course there are times
when I tap my blonde wife on the
shoulder and say hey hot stuff only to
be shocked to see her good friend
turning around to face me you see even
the very best birders get it wrong from
time to time so don't get disheartened
when you make an incorrect ID it happens
frequently and making false IDs is the
best way to learn in my example I use a
suite of ID tools subconsciously to
identify my wife birding is the same way
we need to use a combination of basic ID
tools
and advanced ID tools to really become
accomplished birders now we can use a
field guide to assist us in basic bird
identification in other words the field
guide provides us with a good blueprint
from which to work but a field guide no
matter how good it is struggles to
convey the motion behavior or flight of
birds in the same way observing bird
behavior can so in this lecture we're
going to focus on bird behavior and my
goal is a simple one I want to
demonstrate how a well-rounded knowledge
of behavior can help you become a better
birder okay so what exactly is bird
behavior bird behavior is often referred
to as bird habits the habits of birds
vary just as much as their color size
and shape and can be a very useful aid
in bird identification when you're out
in the field observing a bird you should
ask yourself continually what the bird
is doing its behavior will often give
telltale clues about its identity now
because the range of behavioral
differences can be so vast it's helpful
to organize bird behavior into six broad
categories typical behavior feeding
behavior flight behavior flocking
behavior mating behavior and lastly
nesting behavior let's delve into each
one of these categories and explore how
these habits might aid you in bird
identification first up is typical
behavior it includes the individual
quirks that a bird has that separated
from other birds remember what I said
about my wife's distinctive walk well
this is what we're talking about here
these are the habitual movements that
our bird does constantly and not just
while engaging in other behavior like
feeding or flying once you spend a lot
of time in the field these individual
quirks and subtleties will become
apparent
and of course many of these can be
learned from other more experienced
birders which is why I encourage you to
spend as much time as possible in the
field with local experts let's look at a
few examples of how typical behavior can
assist in bird identification shorebirds
are a broad group of birds that can
present extremely tough ID challenges
especially when they are out of breeding
plumage but the way that a sandal in
runs along the shoreline hugging the
waves is totally unique and their legs
on nothing but a blur of motion even if
it's amongst other similar birds like
semi palmated sandpipers the way that it
runs is totally distinctive another
shore bird the spotted Sandpiper can be
identified immediately by its constant
tail bobbing an unusual teetering
walking style and once you learn this
you will never need to look at any other
detail of the bird like color or shape
tail bobbing as in the spotted Sandpiper
is a form of typical behavior that is
unique to only a handful of birds like
water thrashes Phebe's and a few
sparrows and Warblers Warblers like
shorebirds can sometimes present a
serious ID challenge to new birders but
I know that both Prairie and Palm
Warblers unlike the majority of other
Warbler species Bob their tails
incessantly water thrashes of which
there are two species in the United
States can also be easily identifiable
by the fact that they're constantly
bobbing their tails but the way that
they bob their tails can sometimes be
different between two species and herein
lies the key to using typical behavior
to separate two very similar birds the
Northern Water thrush and the Louisiana
water thrush at first glance even for
experienced birders it's almost
impossible to tell the
apart but if you watch the way they Bob
their tails you'll notice that the
northern species Bob's its tail straight
up and down in a continuous manner the
Louisiana species tends to bob its tail
slower and in an almost circular manner
instead of straight up and down
besides tail bobbing the amount of
activity that a bird exhibits can also
give away clues very oohs can often be
hard to tell apart from Warblers but the
former tend to move much slower and
don't reflect actively and constantly
like the Warblers so that gives you a
taste of our first category of behavior
typical behavior now let's turn to
feeding behavior which can be used on
two levels to assist with the
identification of birds in the field at
the macro level a birds feeding behavior
can assist in categorizing a particular
species into a particular family or
order for example a bird clinging to a
tree and drumming its bull against it's
almost certainly going to be a
woodpecker at the macro level feeding
behavior can also be used to narrow a
larger group into a smaller grouping
that can aid further in identification
imagine you see some birds on a lake
that had flattened Bulls by their size
and shape and the fact that they're
sitting on water you know them to be
ducks but then you notice that the birds
are diving and that they disappear for
quite long periods of time between
surfacing just by noticing this feeding
behavior you know that the Ducks you are
looking at belong to the diving ducks
rather than the dabbling ducks
you know this because dabbling ducks
forage in shallow water appending
themselves sure but never totally
submerging themselves the way that
diving ducks do at the micro level a
birds feeding behavior can be entirely
distinct from any other bird in its
family or order take for example the
obvious case
of the amazing American Dipper the only
songbird in North America that
completely submerges itself when hunting
for its food with its habitats along the
streams of the American West
this bird quickly ducks into the water
to feed on aquatic insects and other
invertebrates feeding behavior can also
be useful when you're observing
shorebirds
which ever as I've noted are a real
identification challenge for all birders
new and experienced to particular
species that can often be found feeding
together our stilts and Piper's and
long-billed archers at first glance
these two species superficially resemble
each other they're both similar in size
and they both have long black balls and
they also have very similar color for
the most part but if you watch the way
that they feed you will notice that the
stilts and Piper's because they're bulls
are shorter than the dowager's and their
legs longer have to tilt down further to
probe in the mud their tails therefore
are more elevated than that of the
dowager's the stilt sandpipers resembles
speeded up land oil rigs plumbing for
oil with their tails sticking up in the
air the dowager's on the other hand feed
in a more parallel fashion and work
their Bulls much like a sewing machine
probing the mud in quick short bursts
still working at the micro level the
wading birds otherwise known as the
egrets and herons provide us with
another great example the feeding
behavior of these birds can easily be
used to aid in identification without
the need for additional characteristics
this is particularly relevant because
many different species of these egrets
and herons can be entirely white and
color Snowy Egrets cattle egrets and
great egrets are always white little
blue herons are white as juveniles and
reddish Egret can quite commonly be seen
as
morphs morph is just another word for a
different variety or color even great
blue herons have a very rare white form
otherwise known as word amongst heron
now it's true that size and certain
other physical features can readily be
used to distinguish between these
different species but behavior can be
even more useful especially when the
birds are at a distance for example
cattle egrets unlike all the other
wading bird species seldom feed in water
and are most often seen in field feeding
on insects disturbed by large animals or
tractors hence their name reddish Egret
are the most active of all the wading
birds their constant dashing around with
wings and legs splayed when feeding has
spawned the analogy of an NFL linebacker
and then there's the snowy egret which
takes this activity level down a notch
although it still actively walks and
jumps around while chasing small minnows
and the shallows the little blue heron
is far less active in fact it seems to
do everything in slow motion it walks
slowly and deliberately towards a group
of fish takes aim and then quickly stabs
then we have the Great Egret and the
great blue herons which are typical of
what we call stand and wait predators
they will often stand against all four
up to several hours in one place just
waiting for something to come their way
it's almost as though they become part
of the scenery until an unlucky customer
comes in reach of that stabbing bull
these unique examples show how all the
white herons and white morphs can be
separated based on behavior alone
feeding behavior at a distance or in bad
light can be very revealing in order to
distinguish between two closely related
or similar species if I see
Pelican spiraling and then crashing into
the water headfirst I know that this
plunge driving behavior can only belong
to the brown pelican species however if
I see a large flock of pelicans
corralling fish on a lake in a
coordinated fishing for a then I know
even if the light is terrible and they
are far away that these birds are white
pelicans some species of raptors use
specific feeding techniques that are
seldom if ever used by other species if
you happen to be in South Florida for
example in winter you might see a Raptor
soaring high amongst a large kettle of
vultures this will more than likely be
the rare short tailed hawk especially if
it's in winter a raptor which uses
vulture kettles as a form of concealment
whilst hunting birds and if you happen
to be in Texas and you come across a
strange Raptor with the crest walking
through a field or patrolling the edge
of a lagoon on foot this might well turn
out to be the unique crested Caracara
okay
so far we've covered two of our
behavioural categories typical behavior
and feeding behavior now let's turn to
our third flight behavior flight
behavior is the single most useful ID
tool when trying to identify birds in
the air all birds have distinct flight
patterns and learning these can make you
look like an absolute pro ask yourself
these questions what does the flight
look like is the flight pattern straight
is it Angela ting or bouncy are the wing
beats fast or are they slow and
deliberate does the bird hover like a
helicopter let's now consider a few
flight patterns that might be useful for
identification purposes woodpeckers and
some other birds
appear to bounce in flight as they
alternate flapping with gliding in
woodpeckers this leads to a swooping or
Angela ting bounce but in smaller birds
like finches the bouncing is quicker and
even jerky this is caused by the bird
actually holding its wings closed for a
brief instant and then quickly splitting
the wings again Raptors can pose serious
identification challenges the reason for
this are twofold many species have
several color morphs and aged images
Raptors also spend much of their time in
the air making a close ID almost
impossible so being able to identify
raptors and flight is often the best and
often the only way to know what you're
looking at
knowing the flight patterns of different
types of raptors can narrow down the ID
challenge to just a few species so that
size shape and color can be supplemented
to nail down an ID some birds of prey
like Falcons and ghazals fly in a dead
straight line using speed and the
element of surprise to catch their prey
others like red-tailed Hawks and bald
eagles circle and saw white tailed kites
kestrels raffling hawks and white tail
Hawks will often hover in the air
remaining in one place with their heads
and bodies still while their rapid wing
beats keep them totally stationary
Ospreys plunge dye for fish sometimes
completely submerging themselves in the
process Harriers are well known for
coursing lower over fields and marshes
in a feeding technique known as
quartering and then there are the
hummingbirds which have the ability to
hover dip and fly backwards like a
helicopter interesting to note that no
other bird can fly backwards so if you
see a small bird backing up in flight
and you're sober you can be a hand
a percent sure that it is a hummingbird
of sorts and then there are other bird
species that have entirely unique flight
patterns these cannot be confused with
any other bird remember the spotted
Sandpiper we described earlier as having
a distinctive walk well this bird also
has a very peculiar wearing flight with
extremely rapid wing beats that is
dissimilar to any of the other Shore
bird species so as with the feeding
techniques you can use flight patterns
and behavior to narrow down your ID at
the macro level and sometimes even nil
an ID straight away at the micro level
whether bird loves singly or in a flock
is a very underestimated but
nevertheless important tool especially
for a beginning birder
and this leads me to my next type of
behavior flocking behavior this is a
tendency of certain species of birds to
form part of a closely knit group of
other birds mostly but not always of the
same species think for a moment how
likely you are to see a cedar waxwing on
its own unless it's sick injured
breeding or very lost this is highly
unlikely conversely how likely are you
to encounter a closely knit flock of
Cardinals unless you're watching Arizona
play football this too is very unlikely
then let's look at a chattering group of
small yellow birds at the top of a tree
this is more likely to be a flock of
gold finches than common yellow throats
which live singly or in pairs in small
shrubby bushes these examples show how
the tendency of a bird to flock can be
quite useful to beginners and as you
become more experienced knowledge of
flocking behavior becomes almost second
nature and serves as an excellent aid in
making quick and reliable IDs
just remember that some birds tend to
flock more at the end of summer when
they gather for migration three swallows
are the perfect example since these
wonderful aerialists stay together in
closed flocks during the winter during
summer however they tend to be found
much more loosely so that gives us an
overview of four of our categories
typical feeding flight and flocking
behaviors our final two categories are
mating and nesting behaviors mating
behaviors are not readily used as a tool
for identifying birds but these
fascinating displays differ widely from
species to species and can make for
really interesting birding birds tend to
use day length and weather changes to
tell what season it is when the number
of daylight hours increases above a
particular level certain physiological
changes occur in a bird that dictate its
time to breed most types of birds will
make sure that they time their breeding
with the seasons when food will be most
abundant for feeding their rapidly
growing babies but well before they
contemplate building a nest and raising
young they need to choose a suitable
mate and then select a breeding site
some non migratory birds will maintain a
territory throughout the year and then
choose a mate either that they've been
with all year or a new one depending on
the species let's take the mute swan for
example a species introduced from Europe
these birds aggressively defend their
territory all year and actually mate for
life other non migratory birds will
actively select and defend a new
territory in the spring and then set
about finding a mate an example is the
blue jay which will wonder more widely
during non breeding season and then
defend a particular territory starting
in the spring but migrate early birds
like many species of Warblers said about
maintaining a territory as quickly as
possible after their arrival from their
wintering grounds once the territory has
been established these birds then turn
to finding a mate or displaying to an
existing one the females of most species
will choose a male based on the prowess
of his mating display his nest building
ability his breeding plumage and various
other display behaviors like dancing or
drumming males will often bring food to
the female to cement the pair bond some
birds such as albatrosses and swans mate
for life
but many male birds choose a mate for
only one season still others choose
several mates in a season in a system
known as polygamy and then there are
even a precious few bird species in
which it is the female that mates with
several males in a system called
polyandry a great example of this is the
northern jacana a bird which is common
in Mexico and which occasionally makes
an appearance in the southern US and is
even bred in Texas so let's look briefly
at some of the more interesting mating
displays watching an understanding
mating displays can be one of the most
enjoyable and rewarding aspects of
birding Western greed couples engage in
a high-energy tandem rushing ceremony
where they run at high speed on the
water with their necks elongated in
perfect synchrony like you waiting ice
skaters it truly is one of the most
amazing birding spectacles to witness
and then there's the male greater
sage-grouse which inflates its air sac
puffs out its neck and erect such tail
feathers and produces a weird popping
sound that can be heard by females from
miles away
male prairie chickens gather in large
numbers at communal licks or staging
grounds yeah they attempt to lure in
females by produce
an eerie booming sound while strumming
their feet energetically on the ground
sandhill cranes engage in a delightful
dance and present each other with gift
and then we can't forget the white
colored and red capped mannequins from
Mexico that perform elaborate dances and
wing snapping displays these are just a
few of the incredible mating displays of
the birds of North America but related
to mating behavior is our final category
nesting behavior nesting can offer
fascinating insight into the private
lives of birds but knowing what birds
build what nest can assist in locating
and identifying a particular species -
approximately 700 species of birds breed
in North America and the variances in
their behaviors are awe-inspiring and
complex at the same time birds go about
finding mates building nests and raising
young in surprisingly different ways
nests are perfectly designed to provide
a safe place for birds to raise their
young they are as diverse as the
different mating strategies of birds
some nests are a simple scrape in the
ground some are elaborate structures
composed of lichen grasses and other
materials others are massive stick
structures that are heavy enough to
break the bow of a large tree nests can
be found just about anywhere from
beaches to buildings to cavities and
trees to bridges to caves and many more
so let's explore some of the most common
types of nesting behavior and see how
nests themselves can give away useful
clues as to the presence of a certain
bird species when most people think of a
bird's nest I bet they would describe a
simple cup shaped structure both of some
kind of vegetation and other material
this is pretty accurate as it is the
most common type of nest
cap structures made out of grass reeds
or other delicate materials are commonly
used by many species of passerines
with some variation this is the typical
nest of sparrows Warblers videos robins
thrashes cardinals and more in order to
successfully identify a nest observe it
from a distance first and see if there
is any activity and remember that many
female birds look very different from
males and can often be harder to
identify take notes so that you can try
and identify the bird later in your
field guide also take note of what time
of year it is resident birds tend to
breed in late winter and early spring
migrator of species tend to nest in
early summer
this is because it takes them a little
time to settle into their new home after
their exhausting migration for example a
pygmy nuthatch in California will nest
in March whereas many of the returning
Warbler species will nest in May or June
and remember that migratory birds tend
to nest earlier in the south than in the
northern states due to the warmer
climate and of course you'll want to
take notes on the nest itself is it on
the ground or is it high up in a tree
what materials are used is there a
lining in the nest have spider web or
mad been used to bind it together
is there any like enormous attached to
the side of the nest for concealment
purposes what is the shape of the nest
is it simple or is it more complex if
there are eggs inside take careful note
of the color size and shape of the eggs
the size of an egg is proportionate to
the size of the bird pointy eggs tend to
belong to birds that nest in shallow
scrapes in the ground or on the edges of
cliffs birds like turns and shorebirds
for example the reason for this is that
the eggs are harder for them
to roll out of the scrape when they
pointy but remember always be as quick
as possible around an active nest and
never touch or move the nest once you
have taken notes on the nest you're
observing you can turn to field guides
and other resources for help in reaching
a positive identification but here are a
few examples of nests to get you started
most pigeons and doug's both very
rudimentary nests of sticks in the forks
of trees large Raptors like Eagles build
massive stick platforms most often right
at the top of trees Orioles actually
weaver nest it is like an elongated
pouch with an opening on the top very
O's usually build a nest between two
sticks of a branch and the nest hangs
down below the fork some species like
chickadees wrens bluebirds and nap
hatches will build a nest inside a
cavity of a tree Phoebe's and swallows
both complicated nests out of mud and
feathers that hang under a bridge
Rockledge or under the eaves of a house
this just scratches the surface of the
many types of nests you'll find in North
America the variety is truly remarkable
which presents as birders with a
lifetime of opportunities to compare
contrast and discover something new and
with that we've reached the end of our
lecture on using bird behavior as an
advanced birding tool in covering the
six core types of bird behavior we've
developed some tools that will help you
navigate the rich diversity of America's
bird species now it's up to you to put
these tools to use so get out there and
train your eyes who knows maybe soon
your friends like mine will be marveling
at your ability to turn subtle quirks of
behavior into a confident identification
you